i have to say i was laughing a little
bit when i was listening to the magnus
episode and the first 10 minutes you
guys are talking about soccer football
two robots seem like human yeah
i was like let's have some fun a
conversation about non-chess related
topics yeah talk about sports yeah it
was kind of hilarious i was surprised
that
uh even at his level
i wasn't sure but i was surprised how
much he loves chess it sounds cliche to
say but like the way he looked at a
chessboard you know those memes like i
wish somebody looked at me in the way
he's still like the way he glanced down
and he reached for the pieces of
excitement to show me something there
was there wasn't like
uh okay i'll show you it was like
like there was still that fire that's
something that always shocks me about
some of like super grand masters like
one of my coaches was a person who also
his name's jim hammer of norway he also
coached
magnus he was his second and he was
helping me train for my tournament and i
was kind of putting off doing the
homework he's like if you're putting it
off that means you're studying the wrong
thing like you should be enjoying even
when you're practicing which when i grew
up i thought to get to the top level
like practicing has to be hard and
unpleasant and when i was listening to
magnus episode he was like i didn't read
books very much there was one thing that
you said that's like very normal for
studying classical chess that he didn't
do just because it didn't interest him
he says i suck at puzzles i don't get
puzzles yeah and he doesn't do what he
doesn't enjoy and that's because it's
like purely driven out of passion i
think the internet was like i suck at
puzzles
yeah they like that
i don't have to study at all it's just
it's fun and uh but i think the lesson
there that's really powerful is he
spends most of the day thinking about
chess because he wants to yeah so do
whatever if you're into getting better
chess do whatever it takes
to actually just the number of hours you
spend a day thinking about chess
maximize that if you're like super
serious about it
you